hello leandro
hello marie how's it going how are you
fine uh how are you
i'm good
uh so i'm
i'm hosting leandro today he's a machine
learning engineer at hugging face and
today we are going to go through the
course parts of uh
causal language modeling and he's going
to show us how he coded the code parrots
which is a causal language model that
can basically write code
anything to add
no that sounds good
shall we get started yeah sure
so let me start sharing my screen
[Music]
you should be able to see my screen now
right
yes
awesome
so i thought just to like set this the
scene a little bit i want to give like a
high level overview of what we
uh what we are doing actually with
co-parrot and maybe one thing that a lot
of people have already heard of is like
github co-pilot
and if you go like to copilot.github.com
you can see what copada can do and what
it is essentially is just a very fancy
like auto completion tool that lets you
write some code and then it completes it
for you and uh i think it's a really
cool tool and it lets you like
it assists you like writing code faster
and so what we're actually going to do
today and what i want to show you with
coparot is like a replication of
copilot and
to see what it takes to build something
like copilot that can generate cope for
you
[Music]
let me
maybe start
with the course we have a
a course um on causal language modeling
because language modeling is the
technology behind copilot because
language modeling essentially just means
uh you're trying to predict the next
word based on the previous words and
models such as gpt
gt2 or gpd3 or typing neo all these
models they're using
causal language modeling in the
background
and if you can predict an expert then
you can continue and predict the word
after that and so on and that helps you
like generate long sequences of text and
these gt2 models or gt3 models they're
really good at that
and in
this chapter of the course
we're showing what it takes to actually
pre-train these language models because
usually when you work with transformers
you only fine-tune them you take a
pre-trained model
from google or facebook or some other
big research lab that built like such a
model for you and then you just fine
tune it but
in this chapter we actually gonna have a
look at what it takes to do the
pre-training of such a large model
any questions so far
and
awesome
um
so before we start like training a large
language model like the most essential
thing that you need is like a very large
data set to to train the the language
model on so the larger the the language
model is that you want to train the more
data you need to actually train it on
and for that purpose we
since we want to build something that
generates code
we used github and decode on github to
generate like a large
[Music]
data set with a lot of python files so
we're just going to do it on a subset
just going to do it for python
if you want to do it for another
language and the procedure is pretty
much the same
you just need to gather
a lot of data for the language that you
want to train on
um
we created that data set and it's
actually available on on the huge face
hub so if you go to transformers book to
coparot that's where you find the full
raw data set with
about like 20 million python files which
are about 180 gigabytes
um inside is there an is there sort of
an api to do this or did you scrape it
yourself from reposs
there is an api from github to to access
like uh
data inside repos but it's as far as i
know it's rate limited and pretty slow
so it's not meant to scrape like the
whole of github
but there is um on google there is a
database that you can query on google
bigquery uh where you can get all the
the the files that are on github so i
think they have like several terabytes
of files and we just
filtered for the subset
um that is python and you can actually
see it here on the dataset card
we we added like the the procedure how
you can get it so you go to
google's bigquery you search for the
github
database and then you can filter for all
the files for example that end with
python and then it creates like a data
set for you
i wonder uh about the application but
maybe we can get to it later when we are
answering the questions because i have a
question about that one
sure i mean duplication is certainly an
issue
we found that
just to give you a rough idea um we
started initial training with like the
raw data set for co-parrot and we found
that the performance was not great and
when we looked a little bit closer we
actually found that there
a lot of files that are duplicated and
like i think the file that was
duplicated the most appeared like 13 000
times in the data set and then
obviously the model that we trained on
that data it was really good at
replicating that one file but it wasn't
so good at like generating uh general
python code so that's certainly an issue
and maybe uh we can have a look at it a
little bit later
that would be nice
sounds good
yeah
good so
um once we have the data set um
we can
essentially
um almost start training we just need to
do a little bit of pre-processing
and what we want to do is
usually we have a maximum context size
for the the model so most models they
can only look at so many tokens at once
uh for example burke it's about 500
tokens
for gpt two i think it's about a
thousand twenty four and cheap d3 i
think it's 2000 tokens that they can
look at
in at once
and
but if we look at the data sets right
it's like it comes with files that are
longer and shorter and somehow we need
to efficiently
um
efficiently transform them so that we
can train the model on them
and
i
have
a little slide
on that i'm just to visualize that a
little bit so imagine that you have a
text and you tokenized it so you split
it into tokens
and maybe
that tokenized text is much longer than
your context size so maybe you're
looking at books and these books are
they're much longer than the context
window of a model
then one easy thing you can do is you
just tokenize the whole text
and you just uh split it with the
context length that you have and then it
might happen that at the end of the book
maybe there's a page that you can't that
doesn't fit well in into one of these
context windows
and then you throw it away
and that works really well when your
tokenized text is much longer than your
context window
but if you have
a context window that is comparable to
the size of the documents
then that can be wasteful for for
example i have here
three samples of tokenized text and i
have a context window
and
if
i
have that if i look at the context
window and compare to the samples you
would see like maybe the first and the
third one we i could use
but the second one i would need to throw
away because it's too short
and that's really wasteful because can't
you just pad somehow
uh
yeah for the for the shorter one
yeah that's one option but
it's also a little bit wasteful because
then you have a lot of padded tokens but
you still have to pass all those pad
tokens through the model right and it's
although they're padded and ignored
they're still computed
in in the model
so you still compute like okay
the the attention and stuff like that
but then after the computation the the
paddings are ignored so that's also not
quite as efficient
so you basically
decide which document you need to get
rid of based on the context size
yeah there's a trick that we can do so
that we don't need to get rid of those
documents and the trick is actually we
concatenate
all these samples
and we just add
an end of sequence token in between so
the model knows that's where a document
ended and that's where a new document
starts and then what we can do is that's
what you can see here at the bottom we
add them all together we have that end
of sequence token in between
and then after we do that then we split
it and then we don't need to throw away
much right then maybe at the very end
of the three sequences there's maybe a
little bit that we need to throw away
and we can scale this up if we do that
for a thousand documents
then we only need to get rid of like of
a tiny fraction of those thousand
documents right and that's much less
wasteful
that's that cool answer your question
awesome yeah
cool so in the course what we do is we
train like a very small version of
co-parrot and it's like little co-parrot
or maybe it's like a
copair chicken
it's like
a small model and what we do is we just
train on very tiny
context windows so it's just hundred
tokens and that allows you actually
that's much cheaper than training a
model with a large context window and
that actually allows you to train uh
that local per model on a single gpu in
like a reasonable time so if you run
that
for a day or two then you already get
pretty good results and you only need
one gpus not an expensive infrastructure
and
in the course in that example we
actually go for that
first approach so what we do is that
stuff here because we have a small
context window most documents are much
longer and then we can
easily do that
but for the real co-parrot we do
actually the other thing where we
concatenate many samples
um
and
yeah you can see here how you um
can do that
let me get to that part
we
[Music]
we load a tokenizer we have a tokenizer
created for code that efficiently
tokenizes code and if you pass
that tokenizer an element of the data
set and you set the truncation to true
if you only do that what that means it
cuts off everything that's longer than
the context size
which is under 28 tokens but we just
said like we don't want to throw away
what comes after and what you can do is
you can return an extra
you can add an extra argument which says
return overflowing tokens which then
makes that
even if like their tokens that are uh
more than 128 tokens look after that
window you still return them and that
makes that windowing for you
and in addition you can also return the
length of each of those
context windows so you can see if you do
that
for uh
for one sample
um
you can see you get many chunks that
have 128 tokens in them
and then at the very end there's one
that only has 41 tokens
is that a returned one
so that's the length of all the
okay those that are returned so that's
the length of all these
things and you can see the last one is
too short
and then we can throw that one away
and
then we can apply that logic to the
whole data set and we do that with like
a map function so we apply
um
that function that we define here that
does exactly what we just did
and then in the second step it goes
through each element and it checks
whether that length is equivalent to the
context length and if it's if it's the
last one then it would ignore it and not
return it
and that makes like a larger data set
than with
training samples that each have like
the context length that fix context
length
and that's pretty much all
pre-processing that you need to do to
train like a little co-parrot
you can then
feed
that data to a model first we need to
initialize a new one
we can do that by
loading the configuration of an existing
model for example here we load the
configuration of gp2
and
then we can define some extra
information for example because we have
a special tokenizer we have to define
like
for that new model what the tokenizer
will look like what the context length
is
and what the beginning on the end of
sequence tokens are
for that model and then that's all to
initialize a fresh
gpt2 model
so you can see in that small
small model example we make a gpt model
that has like 100 million
parameters
good
and that's then all that you need
you can
then initialize a data collater that
makes sure that all your data
is is batched
nicely and then you can pass all that to
the trainer
so you pass to the trainer the newly
initialized model um the tokenizer
some arguments that specify like what
the batch size should be and
yeah how long you want to trade and
things like that the data collater and
that data set that we just created which
has these fixed
context size windows
and that's all the code you need to
train like co-parrot mini
and i thought
what would be cool is now to look at
like the the actual the real deal so
co-parent large
good so
um
in that case i switch over
to the actual code
of copart
you can find it in the transformers repo
it's under examples
research projects
and there you can find co-parrot and if
you go to scripts
there is a script that's called
co-parrot training
and that does
all the training
so there are a few things that are
different from what i showed before when
we train that large model
one we will train it on a
larger um context window we will go to a
thousand tokens
um two we will do it in a distributed
fashion so we don't only want to train
it on like one gpu but
for training
a larger model we need a little bit more
compute so we go for 16 gpus that's what
we use for copart you could also go for
more or less depending on what your
infrastructure is
um but um what are you going to see is
what it takes to like do distributed
training which is something when you
just do fine tuning usually you don't
need to do
and the last change is that instead of
training just a 100 million parameter
model we're going to train like a 1.5
billion parameter model so it's 10 times
bigger than the code by the way are you
currently scrolling because
nope
okay i thought you were scrolling and
yeah
it's fine now yes i just wanted to come
back
yeah so you used you used accelerator uh
for the distributed training
and
yeah
yeah that's the main difference like
instead of using the trainer you can
also use the trainer to do distributed
training and the trainer can do that but
accelerate gives you a little bit more
freedom to
play with the training loop itself okay
so
so the first thing um we're gonna see
like that whole thing is about maybe 250
lines of code but if you would get rid
of the logging and some white spacing
maybe you could get it down to like 150
lines of code so it's actually not that
much code
to train something like copilot
so one of the biggest chunks
that we see here is that
constant length data set that we define
and the idea of that constant length
data set
is exactly implementing that logic here
so you get a few samples from your data
set
you
tokenize them you concatenate them and
then you split
the
long sequence of tokens into these
inputs
and
that logic is implemented here
and you can see there's like a few
arguments that you can pass to that data
set
um one the first one is
infinite
what that means is whether the the data
set should restart once it reaches the
end so we have like
um
200 gigabytes of data but at one point
we're going to reach the end maybe we
want to continue training and if we send
infinite to true then it just continues
so it just restarts at the beginning
um we have a sequence length that's
uh the length of the the
sequence that we want to generate and
then we have
number of sequences and number of
sequences means how many sequences do we
concatenate after another so roughly so
at once so if we set that to 1024
that means we want to get roughly 1024
inputs
at once
and then
once we produce them we start again and
we produce another thousand sequences so
we do we do like a batching of batches
in a sense
and
to estimate how many
texts we need to concatenate to get
roughly a thousand sequences we have
that heuristics here that says
characters per token and we just
measured that with our tokenizer we just
had a look and measured like on average
like a token has 3.6
um
characters and so
what that helps us doing is we know we
want to create 1024
[Music]
sequences each sequence will have 1024
tokens
and we know each token has about 3.6
characters and we if we multiply all of
this we know how many characters we're
gonna need to gather
so
um
and so we know how many uh
texts we need to fetch and once we reach
that number that number the input
characters then we know uh we have
enough to create 1024 sequences with
sequence lengths 1024.
by the way i don't want to interrupt you
but we have two questions one is
is there a specific reason why you chose
gpt to config over something like gpt
neo which has local and global attention
um
not really there's not a deep logic in
that
the main goal was to replicate something
like copilot and
copilot uses like cheap d3 in the
background which has some minor
modifications over cheap t2 but we
thought since we have like gpt2
available we just use that but
having a look at whether sometimes tp
neo performs better on these kind of
tasks would be an interesting experiment
but there
another
question is just asking how long does it
take to train on gpu
without using accelerator
um so i'm not sure i understand the
question i mean gpu is an accelerator
right but maybe the question no it means
like for
accelerate yes i think they mean
accelerate
yeah so accelerate actually doesn't like
speed up the training itself accelerate
is just a library that helps you
easily distribute the training over
several gpus so you could use another
framework that does it
for example in pytorch i think you can
do
uh distributed training in native
pytorch um it's just it is more code and
you need to do more stuff manually but
it doesn't i
i felt like the question actually is how
long does it take on one gpu
uh okay
yeah in that case so i can tell you for
like the large model um we trained two
mods we tried a small cheap t two model
uh with that full context size of 1024
and that took
one day
on 16 gpus so it will take 16 days on
one gpu
and for the large model it took one week
on 16 gpu so it will take 16 weeks on
the one so that's that's quite long
yeah and you don't actually save any
money right
because yeah
they scale with the number of gpus so
um it's better if you
go for the money and spend it in short
amount of time then you wait for a long
time and then you find out in four
months so you had like an issue in your
training
yeah
we can continue if you'd like
we don't have any other questions
yeah so that mind block here um
we do what we do um
is we create an iterable data set
and we're gonna see a little bit later
what why we do that um more exactly but
essentially we don't wanna load the
whole data set into memory because the
whole data set is like 200 gigabytes big
and if we then also tokenize it it's
going to be take up like a huge amount
of space in memory so we would need like
a huge machine and
it comes with a whole lot of issues
and there is a cool feature that you can
use in the data sets library which is
called streaming so you never actually
load the full data set but you just
stream single samples
and so you
you were streaming during your training
loop yeah
exactly that's very good
um
originally we streamed directly from the
hub which is quite cool you can without
needing to download the data set you can
just stream it from the hub and it will
just fetch a sample
yeah it's a really cool feature
we found that at some point we had some
issues with connection so the connection
broke up and then the training got
interrupted
um and so we ended up just storing the
data set locally on disk but still doing
streaming so you still never load the
full data set at once you just
go through the files one by one
and that
and since you're not really like data
constrained like the the the thing that
takes a long time is like the forward
and backward passes and not the data
processing so
um that's not an issue if you do
streaming
and so if you have an iterable data set
you just need to define like what your
iter function does and the iter function
gives you um that that's that's a
generator that yields new samples and in
here
we define the logic
that i previously
mentioned so we have a buffer and the
buffer it will be filled with text until
we have enough characters in that buffer
to generate those thousand sequences
with a thousand tokens
so we have
a thousand sequences
we have a thousand sequence length we
have 3.6
characters per token and we want to
click create a thousand sequences that
means we need to gather about like 3.6
million characters
and so what this does
that loop here does
is
it goes um through the data set so the
data set is in an iterator
and we get like a sample
from the iterator
that's what we do here there's a field
called content that has the the python
file in it and we append it to the
buffer and we add like the length of the
file that we just added to the buffer
length
and once we reach like
once the buffer is like long enough once
it's like more than 3.6
million characters
then we stop so we just gather text
files until we have like enough
characters in the buffer and then we
tokenize all these texts
after we tokenize them
we
can you see it should i maybe make it a
little bit bigger is that maybe a bit
better
it's fine
okay
so after
we tokenize the texts we concatenate all
those texts with that
concatenation token in between which is
like the end of sequence token
so all token ids that will be a very
long sequence with just tokens
and then what we do is we just chunk
them into the sequence length so we go
through that very long array and we pick
out like chunks of 1 24
1024 tokens and we yield those as a
tensor
so that's a data set that you can loop
over and they would always return
a thousand 24 tokens a window of 20
1024 tokens for you
so far so we have also
yeah but we have
three questions if you'd like
uh to answer
so
is deep speed used for the training
um no we don't need to use deep speed so
we used um a100 gpus
and they have enough memory that you
don't need the optimization that deep
speed gives you
if you use deep speed it also comes like
some drawbacks
no worries
if you use deep speed it also comes with
like
some drawbacks in terms of
efficiency right you you need to then
do these extra optimization steps so
that's a little bit slower and since we
don't need it we don't use it
so another question is for the
duplicating the data sets do you think
it would be faster to use bigquery to
remove any
duplicate content or would it be faster
using hugging face data sets
um that's a good question so
you probably could do it on bigquery and
it's maybe
more efficient if you do it that way
but also if you do it on data set it
actually doesn't take that long so since
we do exactly deduplication we only
remove files that have exact duplicates
it takes about if i remember correctly
like two or three hours to deduplicate
200 gigabytes of data which is actually
quite fast
um
i used a machine that had a little bit
more cpus so i had like
uh 16 cores so
that helps but it's still pretty fast so
i i thought like it's not really worth
optimizing at this point
um is code parrots appropriate for
generating sql uh code conditioned on a
task descriptor and some schema info
um i mean the architecture of the model
in general yes but not the model that we
trained because we only trained it on
python code
so it could be that within those python
within the python code that we trained
their sql bits right because people can
also use python to do sql queries
so maybe it works but
i'd suspect it's not great at it so
maybe if you find unit on a data set
that has a little bit more sql data then
it would work better
and i think like if you just want to
create like short sql queries you could
do something similar like in the course
where you have like a very small model
and a small context size to to do it
because you don't need like that many
tokens to describe a query
makes sense
um
so this is a nice question uh how do you
evaluate the quality of code parrots you
did you use something like perplexity
for this one as well um i mean we
measure validation loss and perplexity
during like the language model training
but
evaluating code models is a little bit
tricky so most scores that you usually
use when you generate text don't really
work for code
so you can do perplexity but
that's even if you just do summarization
it's not a very good metric to to tell
you whether you're good at summary
summaries summarization
what you then usually do is like you use
scores like rouge or blue
and but they also don't really work for
code because what they do is they
compare like the overlap of a reference
translation for example and the
translation from the model
but if you have code
like the words that you use within your
function for example they can be very
different right some person maybe names
a variable x and another person names
the variable y in in the code but the
the logic is exactly the same but if you
use those blur and roof scores then you
would get like a very low score because
you use different words so that doesn't
really work well
what we did like for downstream
evaluation is we actually looked at how
well can copar generate code
and there is a very nice benchmark from
openai which they used
in their codex paper codex paper is the
paper behind copilot where they showed
like what they did for copilot
and what they had is like they had a few
programming challenges
and
what the model gets is like the
signature of a function plus the dock
string so
in that case
the model would get
this as an input and then it needs to
generate the function from that
um
yes
i remember that one and i remember they
made like uh
i i don't know which lab did but they
made an even harder
uh
and more categorized challenge as well
after that one because they they thought
that that one wasn't challenging enough
yes exactly they had like some i think
uh
some some other coding challenges of
like
i will post it when i find it
awesome thanks and so what we actually
do then for downstream evaluation
uh we have these coding challenges and
each coding challenge has like a set of
unit tests you can run so the model
generates a function for you and then
you can test whether the function works
with those unit tests
um and then you can see how many of
those unit tests actually pass or how
many functions pass the unit tests and
that's much better for evaluating code
models
and actually just uh
to
show you
that code is also in here so there's the
human eval
[Music]
script
and that does the evaluation
of a model
and you can see that we have two things
in data sets
we have the human eval data set
which has these coding challenges
and we have a metric that's called code
eval which does you can pass a function
and a set of unit tests and code evolve
then sees whether the function passes
the unit test by executing the python
code
that's cool
so
another
one is um
why do you think there there were
problems when you had duplicates in your
data set
[Music]
well so what we found is that
when we
looked at the data set or we evaluated
on these downstream tasks it didn't
perform as well as we hoped for so
like we looked at how well the model can
generate like uh
code and it didn't pass like many unit
tests
so we thought something either
something's wrong in the generation
which i thought that i broke something
so i investigated that for a long time
but what it turned out is that
what i did next is i looked at the
validation loss on some samples and you
could see like there were some samples
that had a very high validation loss
and some samples that i had a very very
low validation loss
and when i looked at the samples with
very low validation loss
what you would see is like
i just then googled these code snippets
that i found in those samples and i
found that they're like very
popular framework so there was for
example numpy code
that had very low loss
and then i thought probably that's
because it's popular and then maybe
there's like duplication so that's why
we do deduplicate it and then after the
duplication we trained another model and
we saw that the
the
performance increased by more than 50
percent so that was a very strong hint
that deduplication was actually the
issue
i mean it changes many things like the
distribution and everything so it just
makes sense that it will perform bad
uh if you had too much duplicates in
your data
yeah to to give you a sense of like how
bad to do deduplication at the
duplication was like we found that
1.1
of the data of the
unique
samples
were responsible for i think 30
of the data
so it's like only a few samples appeared
so many times that they actually
dominated the data set to some degree
and then obviously the model wins if it
learns like these samples right because
then it gets a low loss
so
we have a couple of questions um this
happens like last week there were so
many questions uh the rest of it we went
uh with questions but i i hope it's fine
for you as well
sure
um
this is a collateral related question in
my opinion your data set was several
python files that you just fed to your
trainer model a chunk at the time
the question is
um
so i wonder if this is related to the
sequence lengths and the number of
sequences
here
so what the data set does like what's
happening outside of that constant
length data set is
you actually don't see anything of like
those thousand sequences you don't know
that that's happening under the hood if
you
um get like data
from from that data set you will always
get like one sample and that one sample
will always have like 1024
tokens
and that sequence the number of sequence
that that we get that's just to be
uh
not to waste too many sequences and
concatenate a lot of them
um
before we we
um
tokenize them
so that's actually not what the trainer
will see the trainer will just get like
one sample at a time and the batching
and everything that happens
outside of that data set
i hope that answers that question
are you still there
the internet was gone for a second i'm
very sorry
happens the best of us
no i'm fine
[Laughter]
good um do you have any other questions
maybe we can answer one or two more
questions and then i show the rest of
the script just that we finished that
and then i can answer more questions
um
i'm going to assess if the question is
really nice and
maybe you could answer later in the
discord so
um i'm going to release the
banner uh
but this has changed so if you'd like to
if you'd like to ask your questions to
leandro there is a general event chat
room
at discord i'm going to
list this and you can ask your questions
over there so that we we uh save a
little time with his uh presentation as
well so you can
go on
sure sounds good i mean i'm happy to
answer questions i just thought it's
nice if we can can kind of finish that
and like people get like the general
overview but i think
since uh
the rest is not gonna be so special i
think i can show it fairly quickly
so there's a pretty big chunk of setting
up logging
and i think that's not very interesting
so i don't need to go into much detail
here
just so you know we do like logging with
tensorboard and weights and biases
and at the same time we do like normal
python logging just to
be sure that you store all the important
information somewhere
then maybe the thing that's a little bit
more interesting is creating the actual
data loader
so the data loader is what we then will
need later that generates the batches
and you can see
um here we load the data set
in streaming mode
so the data set name is is the the copa
transplant
and one thing
that's quite interesting is because we
do streaming we can't actually shuffle
the data set globally right because we
never have the full data set we can't
shuffle it
but it might still be good to add a
little bit noise to to the data because
maybe like all the numpy files are
succeeding each other right and then you
have a big chunk that's just numpy maybe
that breaks
your data
your training and that have actually
happened in big science i think they had
an issue where like a big chunk of a
file was just backslashes and then the
model was trained on like a billion
backslashes
and it might sound bad
cool so what you can do but is you can
still shuffle
but you just shuffle a buffer so you can
say
the data set will
gather like a few
files and then it will shuffle those
files
before yielding them
and that helps you like add a little bit
of noise
or a little bit of shuffling to your
data set
and then with that you create your
constant length data set
um that's the things we just saw for the
training we have like the infinite data
set because we just want to
um
get as much
data as we want from it we never want to
stop unless we say we have enough steps
and for the validation we don't want to
do that we just want to validate
every time we validate we want to
validate once over the full validation
set and then stop so we set it to false
and then you pass that to like a normal
pi torch data loader where you define a
batch size
and so what it will do from your
constant length data set it will gather
some samples to fill the batch and then
it will build a batch
um
that's also not so interesting that's
just like a helper function
for the weight decay we don't want to
apply weight decay to the bias terms and
the layer norm weight usually
and that's just the helper function that
splits all the parameters in the model
between those two so the ones that have
a bias or very long neon weight where we
set like the weight decay to zero and
for the other ones we just use the
weight dk we defined
that's another helper function to start
lock some metrics um you can have a look
at it that just locks to weights and
biases and tensorboard
and then that's probably very
interesting stuff starts
that's an evaluate function so every n
steps we probably want to evaluate to
see how well we're doing so we have like
a helper function that evaluates the
model on the validation set
and if you're used to pi torch
then probably that looks pretty familiar
so you don't see much that's like
looks like a
complicated distributed training with
accelerate
except a few things
here we need to apply together function
what the gather function does is if you
have multiple workers it gets the
results from all workers into one place
and gathers them into one list
and then at the end
we return the loss which is the mean of
all these samples
from all the workers that we get
and the perplexity we can easily
calculate as the exponential of the loss
and then we return those
um
good
a few more
things before we can start training at
the beginning you need to
create an accelerator um
there's some housekeeping with like
arguments that we want to parse
um and then one interesting things maybe
is we clone
the
repository from the hub that contains
like the initialized model so we
initialize the model before we run that
script and we push it to the hub
and then we can just clone that
repository with the hugging facehub
library so we
cloned the checkpoint that we call that
like co-pirate when we initialized it we
pushed it to the hub and here we get it
for the training
and you can see here there is
an argument or if
an attribute that we use sometimes in
that script which is its main process
and what that does is
it checks whether of all your workers
that you have with gpus whether the one
that's running that script is the main
process because we don't want to clone
the repository for example for every
worker because we imagine that script
runs on 16 gpus and if then 16 gpus
start to clone the same repository into
the same folder that's probably not
ideal and if you do it's main process
then only the main workflow will do that
step and all the other workers won't do
it
and then
one thing that's quite cool that you can
do is if you're used to git you can
actually create a branch so here what we
do is we create a branch that has an
experiment name
so
when we run that script it will create a
branch on the hub for that experiment
and it will push all the checkpoints of
the model to that branch and then maybe
you run many experiments with different
settings and in the end you just merge
the best model that you have into main
and that's the one that you can then
download from the hub
didn't you didn't you use made some
biases why did you need this again
um we could also i mean you could also
upload your checkpoints to weights and
prices is that what you're saying
no i mean in general like you can
compare like like say it can be
tensorboard it can be comet like you can
compare your runs on everything so i
just wanted to ask oh yeah i mean that's
not for the metrics that's for the
actual models so each model okay
experiment
branch so i can maybe quickly uh show
you that
if you go
to
my model and if you go to files
and versions
you can see there are two branches here
there's the main branch okay and there's
the still spaceship
and if you go to that one and you look
at the commits
you can see
at the beginning i added the model and
the tokenizer and then you can see at
each
50 000 steps i pushed the model to the
hub so then all the checkpoints and all
the models are actually here and you can
still use them if you want them
and if you're happy with the model you
just merging into the main branch and
that's the end model that's here then in
the main branch
i think that's a really cool feature of
the hub that you can actually version
all your models and all your checkpoints
and then once you're happy with an
experiment you just merge it into main
i didn't know the spider
something new every day yeah
i learned a lot today i'm usually like
more of a an alu kind of person than
energy so i am
continuously learning today and it's
been
i have to digest a little and then i
will come up with questions after the
stream
cool
yeah i mean
we're almost done so i think maybe a few
more minutes and then i can show the
rest i mean
here we just load the model we load the
data loaders with the function we
created before
we set up an optimizer and the learning
rate schedule that's also just plain
pie torch it's like nothing special
about that
and the interesting thing
is probably what's happening here so we
have a model we have an optimizer and we
have the train and
eval loader data loader
and we pass them through prepare and
that
is actually where all the magic happens
with the distributed training
so
before that like you have like a normal
model and a normal data loader and after
you prepare them accelerate takes care
to push all the models to all the
workers it takes care of creating a
distributed data loader
um and after that
you can pretty much go back to like a
normal pi torch loop and you don't see
much difference to just doing a pie
torch loop on a single gpu everything is
handled with like that prepare function
which is quite nice
that's really good
i i also uh did not use uh accelerator
previously and it it just looks very
good if you are um if it's very native
uh like if you can keep your native uh
processes then it's it's amazing
yeah
and then this is the
this is the main training loop so yeah
that's the i think the last thing
i want to show is like that's what the
actual training loop looks like
and it's also there's no magic here if
you look at that if you're used to a pie
torch training loop
you iterate over the train data loader
that looks pretty normal
you do a forward pass through the model
with a batch and the labels as patch
because
in causal language modeling the the
input data is at the same time also the
labels right if you try to predict the
next word you just need to shift
the
tokens by one
to actually get the labels
and the model does that internally for
you so if you pass the batch as the
labels it will align the labels and the
inputs
accordingly
we do some gradient accumulation um
because we can't actually train a full
batch even on the large a100 gpu so
um we use the batch size for the large
model of 512
and we have like
16 workers so we have
each at each step if we just do one
fourier pass we have we gather like 16
samples
and we can fit at most uh two samples
into one gpu so that gives you 32
um
samples that you have that you can fit
on these 16 gpus in one pass but we want
to have like 512
um
batches so we just accumulate the
gradients
over several four passes
and that's what you do here
once you have enough
accumulated enough then you do the
actual optimization step
and we also do some gradient clipping
um but that's all like pretty standard
stuff and that's not very specific to
like training do you do this for
accumulation the clipping
uh no the clipping is more like that you
want to get rid of like gradients that
are too large
yeah
yeah when your gradients accumulate like
they also did this also causes exploding
gradients and you do clipping that's why
i want to ask is it related to that
um
i'm not sure that
it is because of
accumulation because
i think the same would happen without
accumulation if you could actually fit
the
the full batch on it because what you do
here is you
divide the loss by the number of steps
you accumulate right so you make sure
that it's scaled
but it can still happen that you have
exploding gradients and then you clip
yeah
i'm learning nice know-hows today
um yeah maybe the only interesting part
is here that's a little bit special like
if we have certain steps we have saves
checkpoint steps maybe that's uh that's
fifteen thousand fifty thousand
um we wanna then
evaluate the model we apply the
evaluation function and after that we
wanna save the model and
you can see here there's a few steps
that are maybe a little bit special and
one is wait for everyone
and that makes sure that all the workers
are ready to actually they have all been
finished optimizing and they're now
ready to do the next step so you
synchronize all the workers and make
sure they're all that on the same page
and the unwrapped thing that just
when you pass the model through prepare
it adds like a layer on outside the
model and you don't want to save that
extra layer so you remove it
for saving and then if it's the main
process
only the main process then pushes that
checkpoint to the hub
and that's quite cool then you have like
all these checkpoints on the hub that
you can readily use
yeah that was great
that's it um shall we like answer a few
more questions
maybe like one or two and then i have to
go to uh a conference and talk there so
[Laughter]
like in in two minutes or so and then
like if you want to ask questions to
leandro uh you can go to our discord
channel and ask in the general event
chat room because we might not answer
all of your questions we don't have any
time
yeah and
questions like written i'm going to ask
one really good question
[Music]
as codex was also trained on python do
you think if a model is trained on more
languages it would improve the
benchmarks
yeah that's an interesting question um
and i mean that's what copilot actually
does right copilot
is the the commercial version of codex
and it actually doesn't only work for
python it works for like many languages
and
in in normal language like in
natural language you have
that thing that's called like
cross-lingual
[Music]
transfer so if you learn something in
one language
language models that trained or trained
on many languages they can leverage that
on other languages so if you train a
multilingual model on sentiment
classification in french and that
multilingual model can also do english
then it also learns a little bit to do
how to do a sentiment
uh classification in on english
um so maybe that would help uh it would
also be more expensive to train because
you need
to train it on more data and more
diverse data
we can wrap up if you'd like um
thank you so much for coming
and
thanks for having me yeah it was great
actually i learned a lot of stuff
uh it's it's great that you can have
your own codex co-pilot at your home
definitely and
just maybe as a last thing you can go to
uh spaces and you can actually
play with co-parrot yourself so that's a
little demo
to show the
the highlighting of code so you can see
which tokens or which uh code parts like
co-parrot things or
maybe have a bug
that looks great
um
you can
if you if you have any other question
you can go to discord um thank you so
much for coming
and all of the
all of the participants thank you so
much uh for asking questions and uh
watching us
uh see you on the next session then
thanks for the questions and bye